honey you are bringing the drama thank
you so much thank you what inspired this
look this fashion moment tonight the
second that i saw this beautiful
carolina herrera piece i just felt like
it was meant for tonight i love it it's
like glam and goth and kind of edgy it's
a moment all of the things everything
carolina does just is the moment you
know
the vmas what do you make of all this
setup tonight i love the vmas and every
time they're in new york it's just the
most incredible energy and i see friends
i haven't seen in a while like bb i'm
excited for all the performances the
fans are amazing my hood keeps coming
off but we're good we're here you still
look fabulous thank you thank you so
much what performances are you looking
forward to
so many people moniskin lizzo i'm so
excited for lizzo
uh bad bunny nikki i mean everyone nicki
and jack and ello
the trifecta that is co-hosting tonight
totally i know amazing what do you think
they're gonna bring to the stage i mean
just the most swag and the most fun and
the most laughs so it'll be awesome it's
gonna be awesome yeah just as awesome as
your fashion this is one of my favorite
looks tonight thank you so much i
appreciate it
thank you so much
[Music]
you